cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous pire
est que j'ai bonjourbonjour sur ce
plateau vous êtes journaliste à vanity
fair votre dernier livre prince william
la vraie vie d'un futur roi vient de
sortir aux éditions du rocher grosse
journée que ce jubilé de la reine
elizabeth 2 pour le spécialiste des
peut-être qu à tout à fait ok avec un
paradoxe peut être pour commencer pas
sûr qu'on voit publiquement celle dont
on va parler toute la journée oui oui on
attendait elizabeth 2 dans cette grande
journée c'est ce qu'attendent tous les
britanniques et même le monde entier on
ne sait pas encore où est elizabeth 2
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle vous savez
elle a passé une semaine à balmoral en
écosse une de ses résidences préféré
pour se reposer elle est rentrée hier au
château de windsor donc le château de
windsor est à 40 minutes de long d'à peu
près en voiture elle est rentrée
d'ailleurs le voyage a été très agitée
il ya eu un gros orage n'a pas pu se
poser c'est est le palais a même dû
publier un communiqué pour dire que la
reine allait bien même si le voyage
avait été agitée et puis là elle devrait
revenir à londres mais elle ne devrait
pas descendre ce mot vous savez cette
grande avenue qui va jusqu'à buckingham
palace elles devraient le prince charles
devrait descendre le maul à sa place et
elizabeth ii elle apparaîtra
certainement au balcon pour un petit
salut et ça sera tout bon on suivra ça
c'est une reine pire est que j'ai au pic
de sa popularité qui fête donc ses 70
ans de règne cette longévité c'est du
jamais vu dans toute l'histoire de la
monarchie britannique ah oui du jamais
vu et puis vous le dise une popularité
incroyable
90% d'opinions favorables c'est aucun
politique aucun chef d'état ne peut ne
peut avoir un tel score juste derrière
elisabeth ii il y a le prince william
qui est très populaire aussi mais il est
dans les 60 % et puis son fils le prince
charles lui il ne dépasse pas les 50 %
donc ce qui est un score tout à fait
honorable vous me direz boris johnson
n'est pas à 50% d'opinions favorables
loin de là mais mais vous voyez que
elizabeth ii elle incarne quelque chose
au royaume uni qui n'existera jamais
plus après elle alors qu'elle incarne
une stabilité vous savez la majorité des
britanniques aujourd'hui n'ont connu
qu'un élan chefs d'état n'ont connu
qu'elle sur le trône 70 ans vous
imaginez et puis c'est le seul chef
d'état encore en exercice aujourd'hui
qui a connu la seconde guerre mondiale
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important l'a vu d'ailleurs tout
récemment encore dans ses derniers
grands discours c'était au moment du coc
vie d'une grande allocution télévisée
enfin je dis grande allocution télévisée
non parce que contrairement aux autres
chefs d'état elizabeth ii n'a parlé que
pendant quatre minutes à la télévision
mais en quatre minutes elle a réussi à
rassurer tout un peuple mais a rassuré
aussi le monde entier ce que n'avait pas
pu faire aucun chef d'état parce qu'une
conclusion dont on s'en souvient elle
avait dit on se retrouvera oui oui elle
avait cité une de ces chanteuses
favorite et elle l'avait dit nous on se
reverra bientôt en effet et il y avait
quelque chose de très rassurant parce
que oui elisabeth ii elle a connu
d'autres crises énormément de crise dont
la seconde guerre mondiale et des crises
plus récente aussi qu'ils auraient pu
écorner son image sa popularité on peut
penser au départ de paris aux oméga nk
site ou encore à l'implication d'andrew
son fils chéri dans la sphère et pikine
oui il ya toujours vous savez la famille
royale c'est un vrai feuilleton c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que ça nous fasse
signe que ça nous passionne c'est une
vraie série télévisée d'ailleurs on en
fait des séries télé et bien sûr il ya
encore des récents scandales des récents
tremblements de terre séisme vous le
citez harry qui part pour le canada puis
pour les états unis le prince andrew qui
est une grande grosse grosse tache dans
le règne d'elizabeth ii malgré tout
parce que déjà c'est son fils préféré
donc en tant que maman c'est c'est une
affaire difficile à supporter et puis en
tant que chef d'état pour l'héritage
qu'elle va qu'elle va laisser c'est
difficile aussi parce que vous savez
elizabeth ii elle son seul but c'est de
laisser en héritage à son fils et à son
petit fils adoré le prince william une
institution monarchique solide qui sera
aussi solide dans le futur qu'elle ne
l'a été dans le passé et dans le présent
mais bien sûr après il ya eu d'autres
séismes certainement le plus grand c'est
quand même les années diana et en 97 la
mort de diana ou pour la première fois
pour la première fois elizabeth ii a été
très impopulaire et pour la première
fois la monarchie a vraiment vraiment
tremblé autre paradoxe qu incarne la
reine c'est l'une des femmes les plus
célèbres du dont on parle le plus
aujourd'hui on a des exemples mais dont
on sait en réalité dans son intimité psy
peu de choses oui c'est une femme très
discrète
d'ailleurs vous savez le credo de la
famille royale et notamment de la reine
say never explain never complain l'on ne
s'explique jamais on ne se plaint jamais
donc la reine ne parle jamais d'elle
vous savez quand vous rencontrer la
reine elle ne vous pose que des
questions sur vous faut il ne faut
surtout pas lui peut lui poser des
questions à elle donc elle ne parle pas
d'eux mais vous savez la reine est une
femme très discrète parce que c'est une
femme très simple qui aime les choses
simples elle aime se promener dans la
campagne avec ses chiens lm sein du sme
à s'occuper de ses chevaux et puis elle
a une vie tout à fait normale elle
déjeune toujours à la même heure elle
dîne toujours à la même heure le soir
elle regarde des séries à la télévision
les séries de la bbc des soap opera elle
fait des mots croisés elle n'a pas une
grande vie de star hollywoodienne vous
savez
bien sa création dans les plus beaux
dans les plus beaux châteaux du royaume
uni voire du monde entouré par des
dizaines et des dizaines de servir mais
vous savez par exemple la reine n'est
pas du tout dépensière elle est allée au
contraire on a souvent dit à un peu
rapide et contrairement au prince
charles qui lui est bien plus dépensiers
à ce cancer en revanche mois peut-être
le rappeler c'est l'occasion c'est que
elle n'aurait jamais dû être reine elle
qui a été couronné à 27 ans
tout à fait tout à fait elle n'aurait
jamais dû être reine elle a été reine
parce que c'est son oncle edouard 8 qui
a abdiqué pour les beaux yeux de de
wallis simpson pour épouser wallis
simpson une américaine divorcée et donc
du jour au lendemain elizabeth ii a
compris quand son père qui est devenu
georges 6 est monté sur le trône elle a
compris que elle serait reine un jour et
alors là pour elle ça a été un vrai choc
elle était encore adolescente et vous
savez elle à prier prier très fort pour
avoir un petit frère à cette époque là
parce que maintenant les règles de
succession ont changé mais
il aurait été roi et donc elle priait
très fort tous les soirs pour avoir un
petit frère et puis ça sa soeur sa soeur
cadette margaret elle voulait être reine
à la place d'elizabeth ii d'ailleurs
elle était margaret était allé voir son
père georges 6 avait dit elisabeth ne
veut pas être reine moi je veux l'être
pourquoi on ne change pas il y avait dit
ce n'est pas possible il ya des lois il
y a pas ce que vous savez c'est une
monarchie de droit divin encore donc
tout ça ne m'est pas possible il ya des
vraies règles de succession mais mais
mais en effet elle ne voulait pas tout à
fait sereine et puis elle l'a surtout
était trop jeune elle n'était pas du
tout préparé vous savez on le dit
souvent elle était en voyage au kenya au
moment où elle a appris c'est d'ailleurs
l'une des dernières personnes au monde
qui a appris qu'elle était reine parce
qu'elle était complètement coupée du
monde dans une réserve naturelle au
kenya où elle vivait elle dormait dans
un bungalow en haut d'un figuier et elle
est montée dans ce figuier on dit
souvent princesse elle en rdc est
redescendu rennes elle a fait pourtant
elle qui donc n'était pas destinée à
être reine de cette fonction sa vie elle
a promis en 1952 aux britanniques de
leur consacrer toute son existence
d'ailleurs elle a accédé au trône non
pas au mois de juin mais au mois de
février en réalité les célébrations sur
la au mois de juin mais le trône
l'accession au trône c'est en février
donc on l'a dit la reine à 96 ans
aujourd'hui problèmes de santé on la
sait très affecté aussi par le décès de
marie philip il est inenvisageable pour
elle d' abdiquer au profit de son
principe de son fils charles
inenvisageable oui vous savez maintenant
on a beaucoup pourtant dans les
monarchies du vieux continent au
luxembourg en et sai on abdique alors au
luxembourg c'est juste par exemple quand
le grand duc qui est l'équivalent du dur
oif ne se sent plus capable de régner il
abdique pour son fils ce qui arrive est
entre gens et henry en espagne c'est
différent au juan carlos a abdiqué pour
des affaires scandaleuses voilà mais en
angleterre c'est tout à fait impossible
pour deux choses comme je disais déjà il
ya quelque chose encore de divin dans
cette monarchie camp lors de son
couronnement elizabeth 2 vous savez elle
devient miren mi-homme mi-dieu me traite
presque et puis vous savez pas ce cas
les chefs d'état mais elle est aussi
chef de l'église anglicane c'est
l'équivalent du pape finalement fin pour
l'église anglicane et puis aussi elle en
a fait le serment quand elle était
encore princesse devant dieu elle a dit
je consacrerai ma vie qu'elle soit
longue ou courte
au royaume uni et au commonwealth et
puis troisième raison je pense qu
elizabeth ii n'a pas forcément envie
d'abdiquer parce qu'elle n'a pas
forcément envie ça c'est mon avis
personnel de laisser le trône à son fils
charles qui ne lui ressemble pas
beaucoup qui est très différent vous
savez charles est un philosophe est un
poète il et il est très engagé très
progressiste sur certaines choses comme
l'environnement par exemple et donc il
ne lui ressemble pas celui ci ne lui a
jamais plus finalement feu et donc
peut-être qu'elle veut écourté le plus
possible le règne de charles hors quotas
en faveur du oui dame qui alliant
williams elle l'a forgée à son image
vous savez william et kate donc sa femme
qui incarne aujourd'hui la vitrine de
l'institution à la meilleure vitrine de
l'institution monarchique d'ailleurs
elizabeth ii ne s'y trompe pas elle les
envoie partout aux quatre coins du globe
pour les voyages les plus importants
tout récemment encore aux caraïbes qui a
été un voyage malgré tout agitée avec
quelques polémiques vous savez on avait
l'impression on a vu kate william dans
une voiture en train de saluer des fous
il y avait quelque chose de des images
qui rappelait un peu les anciennes
colonies et ça n'est pas passé mais en
tout cas sarrès cette famille incroyable
kate william et leurs trois enfants ils
sont superbes ils sont parfaits en tout
point jamais un faux-pas jamais un faux
pli et donc lui c'est la meilleure
vitrine de l'institution monarchique
alors en revanche puisque l'ordre est
ainsi fait et son état de santé sans
doute l'y oblige il ya quand même ces
derniers temps il ya une forme de
transition qui s'est mise en place bien
sûr le discours du trône récemment fait
part charles pour la première fois
toutefois là le charles ne s'est pas
assis sur le fauteuil trop ne sais pas
comment on dit de sa merci c'est quand
même elle la patronne oui oui c'était
pas tout à fait le même trône il était
sur un autre tron qui ressemble beaucoup
au trône d'elizabeth ii mais il y avait
cette couronne impériale d'état qui
représentait elizabeth ii oui il y a
finalement une régence malgré tout une
régence qui ne dit pas son nom vous
savez il y aura une régence vraiment
effective si elizabeth ii un jour
perdait la tête si elle de ness sénile
et qu'elle ne pouvait plus gérer les
affaires mais aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr
charles qui représente elisabeth de
partout par exemple en novembre dernier
aussi à la coop 26 à glasgow elle n'a
pas pu y aller ce discours du trône
aussi bien sûr malgré tout elizabeth 2
continue à rester au courant des
affaires
royaume des affaires de ses autres
royaumes pascal règne encore sur 15
autres royaumes dont le canada la
nouvelle zélande l'australie la jamaïque
et donc vous savez elle reçoit tous les
jours ses raids boxes à ces boîtes
rouges et elle lit encore tous et toutes
les lois qui ont été votées toutes les
lois qui seront votés donc elle reste
encore très au courant malgré tout alors
justement ce sera ma dernière question
est ce qu'on peut imaginer alors non pas
que la monarchie britannique c'est cool
mais lorsque williams sera roi dans dix
vingt trente ans est-ce que ce royaume
sera différent vous l'évoquez ce
commonwealth un qui est né de la
colonisation une quinzaine d 54 états
membres du commonwealth se font partie
ils se sont effectivement sous la coupe
de la de la reine d'angleterre est ce
que est ce que ça ça pourrait changer 10
heures d'où d'ailleurs le fait de les
envoyer dans ces pays là ce qui est
assez incroyable justement si pendant 70
ans de règne et il y avait deux elle
s'est battue elle a travaillé nuit et
jour pour l'unité du royaume uni pour
l'unité de tous ces autres royaumes et
pour l'unité du commonwealth mais là ces
derniers temps elle perd de plus en plus
de couronnes elle a par exemple perdu sa
couronne à la barbade et puis oui on le
sait il ya des des royaumes comme le
canada l'australie la nouvelle zélande
qui par exemple plusieurs fois ont eu
des ambitions républicaine mais il reste
malgré tout attaché à la figure de la
reine le seront ils à la figure de
charles rien n'est moins sûr et donc
peut-être qu'à la mort de la reine tous
ces autres royaumes partiront fin et
peut-être que william il ne lui restera
peut-être on peut l'imaginer que
l'angleterre mais même les cosses vous
savez les indépendantistes sont plus en
plus important les dernières élections
locales une poussée des indépendantistes
en écosse mais aussi en irlande et on
avait demandé aux écossais justement qui
veulent quitter le royaume uni pour
retrouver l'union européenne est ce que
vous voulez garder la reine en chef
d'état il avait dit la reine louis
métrage charles ça on ne sait pas donc
oui après charles williams sera
peut-être uniquement roi d'angleterre et
puis il l'a dit lui même je ne serai
peut-être plus chef du commonwealth et
après tout c'est comme ça c'est
l'histoire bon elle sera sans doute plus
là pour voir ça du coup et peut-être
tant mieux pour elle du coup merci
beaucoup merci merci et très bon courage
à bout pour cette grosse journée le
cumul et je sens qu'on va retrouver ce
soir sur l'antenne de france 24 merci
encore pierrick jeu c'était passionnant
votre dernier livre prince william la
vraie vie d'un futur roi dont vous nous
parliez à l'instant qui vient de sortir
aux éditions du rocher bonne journée bon
juste après la pause avec avec ma reine
à moi pauline godard
[Musique]